coming out of the closet as a trump
supporting drag queen
was difficult i lost a lot of friends
but it was worth it
and i realized i will never go back into
the closet again
trump 2020 right now
i did it as a mormon i did it as a
conservative drag queen
and from now until the day i meet jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
i grew up mormon and i came out of the
closet as a gay mormon
and that was difficult i go to trump
rallies
in drag number one to show the world
that trump supporters are not homophobic
evil bigoted awful monsters they are
loving they are tolerant they are kind
you are prince maga today and if antifa
shows up
or black lives matter shows up you smile
and wave
because you know that your royal guard
is going to take care of it absolutely
crap boys it's so different once you
have the hair
and the jewelry and the nails we are
ready to go
and we are ready to fight for america
[Music]
lady magga lady
[Applause]
[Music]